we're live
all right with the right intro by the
way with a new guest with us today a new
friend
a good friend from chicago
bulls tom zenner who's been on tv for
many many years to interview michael
jordan tom it's good to have you on with
us
hey guys first of all congrats on this
podcast yes it's it's i've watched it
for so long now i'm on it so thank you
for the invite i'm really happy to be
here i'm excited
yes we're looking forward to it and uh i
know tom has got some strong opinions
uh uh if you grew up in chicago you know
the face
you know some of us never had a chance
to watch michael play you ever got a
chance to watch michael player now
back in the day when he came down to my
watch yeah
he had a chance to do more than just
watch him so you would hear this intro
and now
yeah from the chicago bulls
well first let me tell you what topics
we got and maybe we can go into a story
with that
so we got a pretty jam-packed uh uh uh
episode today we haven't done a podcast
i think since last
uh matter of fact no it's been over a
week because uh last week was convention
week that's true
we had 16 000 of our agents we did our
first
virtual annual convention with uh uh
general mattis with trey gowdy and with
pitbull which he crushed it by the way
and uh but we are back we are back to
beyond with you here's the topics of the
day
i got an email from goldman sachs and
this email from goldman sachs is going
to talk about taxes
and it talks about biden's tax plan let
me put it to you this way
when i shared this email with our buddy
adam
adam immediately said there's no way
that's true
he went into verifying all the stats and
the numbers he could not believe
what the new tax plan of biden is we're
going to talk about it today
that was sent to investors at goldman
we'll talk about that
then we'll talk about what happened with
the founder of zoom uh
ceo yesterday you know his net worth had
a pretty good day a couple days ago
i've never heard of his name before yeah
that's right now you do you make 6.6
billion in a day
the most anonymous billionaire in the
history of this planet crazy anymore
though
craziness i still couldn't tell you his
name yeah craziness
and and then we'll go into amazon drone
program which is uh ready to lift off
and it's pretty crazy what they're doing
delta
american made a big announcement after
what united did
uh biden a record-breaking campaign
which that's a big victory for adam
adams predicting that for a while
a little glitch with covet cases coming
from cdc
nancy pelosi who goes to the same hair
salon as
i think adam's been there a couple times
before so you wouldn't let me in these
days literally got in
little scandals there and then a senate
bill california last but not least again
we got more topics but we may even talk
about
i don't know if you guys heard about
that you know we've all done sales
before
you're the top sales person in your
company it's a big deal yeah you've done
sales for a while you've done sales
before
i've never the stats i saw yeah u-haul
announced
their sales person of the year get out
of here they have
over ten thousand sales people uh
announced their greatest
salesperson of the year wow they have
never
seen a better salesperson than this let
me hear this i wanted to hear the
scripts
i wanted to know how you overcame
objections right i wanted to know what
people say when it says pricing i wanted
to know what the strategy was
for u-haul's greatest sales person of
all time
how do you get so many people to buy
u-hauls
how do you do it i mean there's got to
be a strategy to it years ago there was
a book called how to master the art of
selling by tom hopkins
and tom hopkins was known for selling
366 homes in a year
that's one a day so he wrote a book
about it he this man ought to write a
book well think about the skill in
selling u-haul because
how do you convince someone to drive
some somewhere 300 or 400 500 miles
with just am radio and no air
conditioning have you been in a u-haul
lately
they are the most not the most expensive
vehicles in the world right
it's not got the windows that go down
like i mean you got to be a master
salesman can't listen to a podcast no no
no you can't do any of that stuff so i
gotta hear what's going on with you
so u-haul sales person of the year
goes to can you please put the picture
up so everybody can see oh wow governor
newsom so first of all
let me just give you some stats here on
uh what uh our friend here in california
is doing to everybody who's in
california
shout out to your governor just an
incredible type of a governor who
is able to do great things with u-haul
because here's the numbers for u-haul
just so everybody knows
the cost to rent a 26-foot u-haul u-haul
truck
big enough to move a three to four
bedroom home out of san francisco
headed to las vegas reached as high as
two thousand
eighty five dollars for four days okay
u-haul
the same truck to rent to go in the
opposite direction
132 wow let me say this one more time
yeah to go from san francisco to vegas
but 132 dollars to go from
vegas to san francisco tom you're from
california why do you think this is
happening well you don't really live in
california live in l.a
you know it's what a strong picture of
really something
very edgy he looks like a sales guy it
looks like legit sales
hard to say no to that guy you know it's
legit it's real i live in los
angeles you know the only good thing
about this for people leaving california
is there's no traffic
right with the pandemic there's no
traffic in l.a you can get out of there
even quicker right now
i have a good friend who's one of the
top real estate agents in phoenix he
says there's no inventory
so many people are moving to phoenix i
heard a stat i don't know if it's true
they swore by it i heard one out of
eight people that are moving are moving
to maricopa county in arizona
i mean so there's an influx of people
that are actually leaving it's true
it's real and you know what here's the
sad thing
he's gonna be employee of the month for
a few months in a row because it's the
tip of the iceberg
i mean it could get worse if the
election goes a certain way there's
going to be
more people leaving california than
there are now so it's a real deal i mean
he has earned that status he is
single-handedly
responsible for people leaving
california what do you
to gavin news i actually have more of a
question i have a couple questions i've
never lived
in california i've done some summers
there i want to know you're from
california i mean obviously va ran
um you've lived in california for six
years now you went to college there
so here's my question to both you what
are the chances you would move back to
california
and what are the chances you would move
out of california so the u-haul
you know crossroads right here what are
the chances you would move back to
california with
the current climate right now i would
say slim to none on my
end so you got to realize seven months
ago we were thinking about going back to
california was one of the spots and it
was at the top of our list because i
lived there for 24 years right outside
of the army
but uh the way the politics are right
now the my dad lives in uh a
small city called granada hills okay i
lived in granada hills for eight years
granada hills nice place it's got a nice
park decent community
nothing crazy it's definitely not high
it's not low
it's right in the middle moderate i like
the sound yes and
i lived there for eight years and the
other day my dad sends me a video of
outside where he lives the park there
are hundreds of homeless people
laying out outside of his house i said
i've never seen this before
i don't even know what he says pat this
just happened the last year year and a
half i said what do you mean
he's sent me sending me the video i'm
seeing people laying out all
on the side i'm not talking one family
too full-on
tents set up i've never seen this before
i mean what's happening right now over
there it's quite scary i mean
they came out with a new senate bill
that just got passed
you know a a couple days ago which we
can talk about here in a minute but
yeah it'd be very hard for me to go back
you're not going back pat you couldn't
afford to go back there literally it
wouldn't make sense
you've been there for six years well it
breaks my heart i mean i love california
you know i grew up in minnesota in a
small town 700 people
on a dirt road literally very rural i
just wanted to get
to california that was the dream i'm
sure pat had that dream i did too
growing up in minnesota i went to co i
did everything i could to get to go to
college there got a football scholarship
i said the first school in california
that gives me a scholarship i'm going
i went there basically didn't know
anybody's sight on scene i just want to
get
to california it kind of it breaks my
heart to see what's happening
you mentioned the homeless situation
where your dad is i always kept saying
okay we know it's bad in downtown l.a
and when i say it's bad it's
unbelievable
if you get rerouted if you're driving
around la and you have to go through
downtown
it blows your mind i mean just to see
the encampments everywhere and to think
that leaders don't care or this this
isn't a problem
how do you just allow the encampments to
continue to move
west which is what happens okay so i
kept saying what happens if they get to
brentwood
they're in brentwood all along san
vicente now i mean there are tents
everywhere you look what if they get
into beverly hills you know it's just
there's no stopping it i live in
manhattan beach
a very nice beach city you know in the
south city yeah and and
it's it's like a it's like a a
slow-motion movie you just sense
change and you almost feel it it's
little by little but you do
sense it's different i get how people if
they have the opportunity if their lease
is up if they can sell their house
because real estate is still hot
in southern california so people can
make money on selling their house but
they are bailing in droves and the other
thing too is
you know you live in los angeles we have
you know friends of all
political backgrounds but mainly
democratic and liberal
but you just hear differences in the
conversations right now the way people
are talking so
who knows he's earned the status of
employee of the month for u-haul
i bet u-haul really is this could be
like zoom when we see their earnings
here
they're gonna be billionaires they gotta
follow they gotta send them a check to
say thank you so much
governor newsom for being a top salesman
of the month for us back to back to back
just a legendary salesperson of uhaul
uh but do you think he puts it on his
resume he should
it's depends he's applying for depends
on what job he's applying for after
being a governor so
you know you showed something earlier
you said this is why i love florida
because in florida
yeah politics is not as ugly as you're
saying it is in some other states yeah
how is politics in florida well you're
about to find out sir will you tell us
how you
you've been there for a while florida is
sort of like um
a mirror of the united states you've got
north florida which is
i went to college in north florida
florida state which is a little you know
it's basically the south
you know it's just south alabama south
mississippi south georgia
cool you've got middle of florida
orlando
family fun kids that kind of a vibe
you've got um you know retirement
communities you've got then you come
down to miami you have
the latino community you have the
haitian community you've got
south american community you've got the
jewish community it's really just sort
of like
uh a mere image of what the united
states is and politics is not that ugly
in florida that's why every year
the freaking election hinges on florida
are they a little bit more you know
liberal these days they're a little more
uh conservative these days
we have we have republican senators
we've got republican governors we've got
democratic governors got
it's it's not as ugly it's not as
divisive so that's why when i hear
things about california i'm like
more inquisitive like what the what
going on in california you should you
should do a
project for your life and go and live in
san francisco for five years yeah well
i'd lived there for five days
and how was it no i took my girlfriend
there she wanted to leave on the first
day
which i had to convince her i mean one
of your girlfriends
tell us how it was five days you went to
school so we did a we started in san
diego i did this trip every year
for the last you know six seven eight
years uh but
usually i used to do it with like the
homies but now i took my girl we started
in san diego we went to la we stayed in
la we did the
up the coast um what's the coast i'm
thinking of what's it called the one the
yeah
yeah all that carmel monster stuff we
did what's the uh specifically big sir
yep big sur so we're building up and and
we were flying back from san francisco
to miami so we're like oh my god we're
so excited we've never been to san
francisco
we had recently been to new york like
it's kind of like the west coast new
york we're excited we're excited we're
excited
we get there we check into our hotel the
hotel was a little bit
uh they weren't ready for us we had this
room whatever point is we say hey look
while you're getting all ready for a
room we're going to take a walk out on
the streets
we just they said hey do do us a favor
don't go that way
or told you they told you don't go that
way because this is 10 o'clock at night
on a wednesday
don't go towards union station square
square yeah don't go that way go that
way
that's a little bit more fun so we go
that away i swear to god within an hour
she's like get me the [ __ ] out of here
this is the most disgusting place i've
ever been
i'm like babe whatever let's check into
the hotel let's you know
we'll figure it out the next day i went
and i returned the rental car that we
were using
i literally called her i was like we're
staying i found fisherman's wharf
it's cool it's cool down here touristy
area there's walruses there's seals what
have you
it was nice we ended up having a couple
you know three four days that were nice
but that first day in san francisco well
it's shocking because you think you
san francisco you have this preconceived
notion it's beautiful it's on the coast
great skyline clouds i mean just
beautiful and then you get there
and it hits you in the face and you see
it and you smell it
that's the other thing about when you go
to san francisco right now i mean
it's real it's palpable i mean there's
no question and it's a tragedy it's just
it's unbelievable
is it a great american city is it the
economy is it silicon
valley is it 1 000 politics
of course it is it's 1 000 politics
politics determines that
not every city in america is like that
why san francisco like that
you know and by the way i don't know if
you guys heard it or not one of the
salons was open this week
one of the salons oh is that right and
one of your good friends
nancy pelosi went to the salon she
called me she called me for the hook
hook-up
i got her in hey kai can we see this
video of nancy pelosi going to the salon
i mean honestly
we got to see this video kai's been up
in this game with videos lately
look at that that's nancy pelosi watch
your step
good boom good for her she didn't [ __ ]
in the highest level
how irresponsible to not put a mask on
at her age
you know what my first impression of
this is okay we all know politicians
take shortcuts they expect preferential
treatment that doesn't shock me
she's doing that the mask thing bothers
me more because
in california they'll give you a fine if
you don't have one on
i mean they're constantly in your face
that you like walk across the street
they have mass police
in some cities you know if you don't
have it on they're harassing you the
fact
she's getting her hair done doesn't
shock me but not wearing a mask
is a slap in the face to everybody
that's how to change their lifestyle and
wear one all the time it's ridiculous
now that the challenge is so she the
owner of the salon
decides to kai if you can move it up a
little bit so we can see the picture
the the owner of the salon decides to
release this video
so they asked her why'd you release the
video she said i thought it was fair
because
other salon owners have been shut down
and they asked me to open up mine and
it's a community and i would also be
protective of them
so i open it up what do you think about
her opening up the salon for pelosi
and then sharing this video with the
public
so i'll give you you know two sides of
the coin here right so
obviously the optics of this are
horrible i mean this is hypocrisy at its
finest breaking news everybody
politicians uh don't always uh do as
they say do as they do right i mean
they'll tell you one thing and then do
what they want to do right so
that's that's nancy thing however you
could take the other side of the coin
which i'm sure nancy's saying is
you set me up bro you set me up i called
you up
you know it's gonna clear the space just
for me no one else in there
there's nobody else in there except for
me and my hairdresser and then you rat
on me
so i i do am i a fan of what she's doing
am i an advocate of nancy and her
hypocrisy
not at all however i'm sure she's
basically saying she was set up is that
what her defense is
set up getting your that's not a setup
okay that that it's being exposed
the mistake the salon owner made is not
calling tmz and making money off it
hopefully
that salon owner made money off this
video right because her shop has been
closed
for five months so hopefully that she
was able to capitalize on it and then
did you happen to see that the next day
that they start lifting some of the
limitations in california yeah that's
saying that now you can open barbershops
and salons with limited people inside
amazing timing isn't isn't governor
newsome pelosi's nephew
i don't know if they're actually related
check to see if there's
their relatives because i saw somewhere
that news newsom
uh related right they're related to
pelosi they go click on that
uh gavin newsom uh related to pelosi
he is the brother-in-law of nancy pelosi
the speaker doesn't remember
brothers he's a former uncle let's talk
about ron pelosi
no i'm talking okay so then that would
be
so it looks like maybe her husband
somehow was related okay
interesting there's some kind of guy
click go back to that guy and just click
people also ask just scroll down how is
governor knows somebody to go to
the top one kai top one boom
click on that while in school newsom
spent the semester studying abroad in
rome newsom's aunt was married to ron
pelosi the brother-in-law speaker of
the united states of house
representatives there's some
relationships it is
when you think of gavin newsom his
ex-wife is completely guilt i mean it's
unbelievable you know here's the other
thing i love about this story is yet
to come whoa
the fact that nancy pelosi is 80. that's
what i learned from this story as well
she's 80 80 years old forget term limits
there should be age limits on congress
people
there really should be there she should
not be allowed to be walking around
san francisco i actually all right we're
starting to agree over here president
74 years old right here she's 80.
age discrimination and then you've seen
the scenarios right if they can't pick
the winner of the election that she
could
somehow become the president as speaker
of the house 80 years old
unbelievable how old is this troll is
he's 74 74.
76. biden 76 i thought he's 78.
c74 go to biden 77
77 all right meet us halfway november
12th
he's about to be 78 by the way in the
next few months
so he's either going to have a huge
party when he turns 78 or he's going to
freaking uh
by the way your name is barack obama
you're a two-term president
a one-term senator and you're not even
60 yet
gangster right there i actually think
about that for a second you're
59 you're a two-term president a
one-term senator and you're not even 16.
can we see it before you compare
to other politicians yeah exactly let's
take a before and after picture of
barack when he
became the president at what was it 48.
honestly i don't look at that hair
though dude
click on it on pictures i don't i mean
you know they're going to pick the best
and the worst pick of him i mean yeah
and that could be
i don't think that's a little bit too
far-fetched 2009 2016.
yeah i don't know i don't know if it's
that bad of a picture but
the mole got bigger though the what the
mole moles do get bigger
okay let's take a look at trump 2015
2020 is he tanner now his tan got a
little bit stronger i think it's what
happened with him
that he's doing every day for an after
bleach uh before and during
office uh
it just depends going to be posting the
photos
okay listen you know we talked about you
know obviously we took a shot at tequila
before the show just to warm things up a
little bit right
you got me thinking don't don't don't
get us involved with your double shot
you didn't do it come on mr miami i'm
the only one that did it
unbelievable what would it just picture
this picture this
you got before they're doing a podcast
you got obama
on one side he's got a glass of tequila
scotch you got trump on the other side
just two dudes hanging out
two dudes no cameras cameras off what do
you think that conversation sounds like
they just took a shot even though trump
doesn't
are they both presidents or pre-prep
after president
i've talked in 2020 and beyond right
well they're after presidents they're
like what's up man
you know obviously we don't like each
other didn't take the tequila he's never
drank
right now hypothetical but if they did
just having a conversation i think trump
is so competitive he'd still be talking
[ __ ]
to obama's face he's trump is the super
trump is like jordan 32 years later he
wants to remind you of that you know
shot he made over you that's him he
can't help himself he's that competitive
not competitive people say today
competitors who ran into jordan he's
still reminding him of him and when i
hit that shot on you buddy till today
that was 40 years ago two other
characteristics of these guys though i
think is they both want to be liked i
i think they have when you're in that
role of president and it's so
partisan you have to play a role as
president and and some of that
i don't know if it's natural or if it's
acting or what i i my opinion is they
don't have
a severe hate maybe now because things
got very personal between them
you know during at the end of when trump
was campaigning
but i i've heard obama is a super cool
guy to hang with i bet he'd be pretty
fun if you could
if you could keep politics out of it i
bet it'd be a fascinating conversation
what do you think obama's saying
well donald we're going to have to talk
don't you think
for trump you know he loves celebrities
and he always did that's why he did
celebrity apprentice he just
he goes to all the parties he loved it
the fact that me uh hollywood has turned
on him like they have
and wall street and new york and madison
avenue and he's so hated
i bet that tears him up because he likes
he wants to be like yeah i
i agree and you know it's crazy by the
way if you're watching this and you're
with us we got 14
15 so far with us uh our record is i
think 16
50 or 16 15. nice crew if you're
enjoying the podcast put a thumbs up
and uh hit the subscribe button but you
know i had alan lichtman
on yesterday with me and alan lichtman
if you know who he is he's a historian
and he's a historian who years ago
back in the early 80s late 70s he ran
into a russian man named vladimir
and vladimir was one who had a
technology to predict earthquakes
okay alan lichtman he meets vladimir
this man's the expert at predicting
earthquakes
what a job to have he predicts
earthquakes so he comes up to alan
and says hey i want to collaborate with
you allen's worried he's thinking this
guy's tied to the kgb he's like wait a
minute listen i went to
american university i'm a phd from
harvard
i'm the scholar i don't i don't want to
do anything with you man what are you
talking about
why don't we collaborate so check this
out they collaborate together
kai did you bring the notes yeah he
brought the notes here they decided to
collaborate together and here's what
happens
he ends up coming up with 30 different
markers
to predict the election okay from the 30
they narrow it down to 13 the top 13
that matter the most
out of to 13 two of them are about the
candidate the other 11
is not the other 11 is more about the
current conditions two of them is about
the candidate right
then they go back from 1860
to 1980 and they look at every single
election
with this guy who predicts earthquakes
and they come up with a format
and they come up with a formula and they
say we have figured out the formula
two years before 1984 election when uh
uh
when uh um reagan reagan becomes
president
in 1981 matter of fact he predicts that
reagan's gonna win
office and he's gonna become president
everybody thought he was crazy
from that moment till today every single
one of the predictions he's gotten right
now here's a key fact to know about this
guy here
he's a die-hard democrat he's not a
trump guy
he went on bill maher talk trash about
republicans he says republicans have no
values but they have a spine
democrats have values but they don't
have spine and during the predictions
that he made five of the winners he
predicted were republicans for them were
democrats
he chose trump to win in 2016. but
here's what he said yesterday when we
sat down
he said based on these 13 markers this
is his prediction by the way based on
these 13 markers
he predicts that as long as you get
seven of these on your side you become
president so i said let's go through it
party mandate we're gonna do this now
we're gonna go through this i'm gonna
actually say what he said okay
okay party mandate after the midterm
elections there's 13 markers the first
one is party mandate
after the midterm elections the
incumbent party holds more seats in the
u.s house of representative
than the previous midterm elections this
favors who democrats because democrats
haven't
won the midterm you got it number two
is a contest there's no serious contest
for an incumbent party nomination
trump is the incumbent so he doesn't
have anybody that's so that favors who
republicans so we got we got we're
keeping score here we got one widen
one biden one trump so far okay then he
goes to incumbency
the incumbency party candidate is a
sitting president that's trump that's
trump so that's true for trump yes
then he goes third party is there a
third party that's competing like a ross
pro
no joe jorgensen cannot do anything and
jorgensen is definitely not going to be
an accountant trump's up 3-1
trump is up 3-1 based on his prediction
so far okay
then you go to short-term economy how
the short-term economy is not so good
this one believe it or not he gave to
democrats he says this is on the
democrat set which we'll get back to
here in a minute he says well
the economy's in shambles we have a
recession there's no way in the world
this favors trump et cetera et cetera
trump three to trump then long-term
economy
are are americans hopeful about the
future of the u.s economy
he gave this also to democrats he gets
us to bite and he says americans are not
hopeful about the future of the economy
tie ball game now it's a tie ball game
then he goes to the next one which is
policy change the incumbent
administration
affects major changes in national police
he says trump created a ton of his
policies
he brought him in the wall all this
other stuff he threw away all of obama's
policies
that's right trump then he goes to
social unrest number eight
yeah yeah we don't have any questions
about this one four four then he goes to
scandal
there's scandal with trump so he's going
to give this to now biden just took the
lead ladies and gentlemen the lead
fighter the old man
and military failure he gives this to
republicans
yeah there's not been no major there's
been no failures no failures
then he goes to foreign and military
success not a huge a lot wait a minute
not a huge opinion are you kidding me
but that's your opinion
yeah he says democrats take this okay
well he's wrong there
i mean we're gonna get to this on the
wrong part because i'm with you but he
gave that to democrats
yeah then this is the next one which
it's mine
i mean the fact that he chose it this
way it's mind boggling
incumbent charisma does trump have
charisma
you know what he says he says no he
doesn't have christmas he says
he says he said okay you want my opinion
yeah he said does he have charisma
maybe it's his words but only to his
base okay we'll come back and debate
that's what he said though did he not
say that no
okay i'm not making this up and then the
last one he says
does the challenger have charisma i know
he says absolutely not he said no so he
gave that to
trump so we got seven six trunks we got
seven six bites it says obama
i mean biden ends up beating trump so
here's what i said seven six
seven six now we open up for debate now
we open up for ding ding ding ding ding
so
which one of these are open up for
debate i got three of them open for
debate right
i got three of them open for debate okay
one of them is
short-term economy yeah the other one is
long-term economy
the other one is his charisma yeah and
the other one is
military success i was gonna say foreign
policy uh foreign potential success
so there's four that you want to bring
up well i have this short-term economy
long-term economy
foreign uh military success yes and
history charisma so we got four so which
one you want to take first let's start
with
by the way if everybody's watching this
would you categorically say
that trump is a very charismatic guy
whether you like him or not comment
below of course
if you say trump is a charismatic he
wouldn't have been elected in 2016.
that's what got him elected
charisma so he's saying he's saying just
with his party is what he's saying
what are your thoughts pat here's my
thoughts did you know about the 14th
question
that lickman has here it is is lickman
a quack and the answer to that is yes
okay
so he hangs his he hangs his hat on
getting every election right since 1984.
congratulations ronald reagan over gary
hart
what a bold prediction in 1984. so he
gets that one right
did you also notice that these types of
guys there's always one
every election cycle that got the
election right every year since 1923
right there's always that one guy and
then they get it wrong
and then it falls off to the side here's
the other thing throw
all his little questions out the window
because 2020
you can't compare any other year to 2020
it skews
everything this guy's a quack the other
thing too is
when when some left-leaning media
publications report this it's almost
like a mic drop for them oh
lickman said he's gonna win it's over
right they take so much
satisfaction and pride over i don't buy
these guys and here's the last thing
that makes me think he's a quack he
predicts earthquakes
the only person that can predict an
earthquake is paul giamatti in the movie
san andreas did you ever see that yeah
may god help us all do you i love you
anyway so that's my my take on lickman
the fourteenth question i mean i gotta
totally disagree with tom on this one
tom
uh he predicted trump would win in 2016.
let's give the guy a freaking credit
that's called luck you flip a coin on
some of these okay listen
if you've got number one some russian
dude in your corner that's
busting out some crazy systems and stats
you you boy you have 30 as pat said then
you boil it down to 13
and you go back from 1860 to 1980 and
you have your you run your numbers and
you bring your points actually
he's got a system dude he's got a system
he's not a quack
now you might disagree clearly that he's
not a prophet either i mean he's been
dude i'm not praying to the lichtman god
i don't give a [ __ ] about this guy
however he does have a system and is the
system
proven to be right sure we're gonna find
out in two months if he actually has his
you know if the system can you know hold
water in a very very close election
clearly um reagan over mondale 1980 oh
my god how'd you come up with that one
but uh gore bush the closest election
we've ever had
in our country's history predicted that
one um
he predicted 2016. he actually predicted
i think
um gore would win the general election
i think those are the that would be the
caveat with their two days
which we've all learned in this country
general election you mean the popular
vote i'm sorry but those popular books
predict
well clearly that we've all learned
there's a big difference between the
popular vote
and the electoral college sorry for my
confusion right there but
the bottom line is i think the guy has a
system and
we're gonna see if it can uh you know
hold water on this one
but back to the charisma i want to go
through specifics by the way i just
asked
here's who said no majority said yes
bobby
nikolovsky said trump doesn't have
charisma
almost everybody else says of course yes
absolutely
deborah wade says yes he is knight fury
says joe hidden
and then you go let's see who else says
no i mean it's like 90
is no he does not blaze herself
and then you got a few other people that
said no vinney
their car said no okay so 90 say yes
that he has charisma but let's go back
to it yeah
okay short-term economy i don't even
want to
because the part that i question him i
actually like his system
i don't think i dislike the system he
says there's a part of this that has to
do with your own judgment because some
of the things it was based on opinion
right when he said this so short-term
economy gave it to the democrats
how do you give the short-term economy
to the democrats
when we had the conversation yesterday
here's what i said yeah i said
well first of all the day trump took
office november 9th
he takes office market goes up 250. okay
it was at 18
559 the day he took office trump took
office
the dow went from 18 559 to 29 000 and
change
as of yesterday that's 50 something
percent
so short-term economy check now let me
go even a little bit deeper than that
with short-term economy
then he said well it's not necessarily
true the american people are struggling
right now they're this they're that it's
a recession
i said this is not a recession this is
not a tip he said this is a recession
i said look i went through 0-1 recession
9 11 when it happened and you kind of
saw what happened to the economy that
went to 6 500 people were scared
people lost money i remember 08 when the
mortgage crisis took place and people
were losing money
even though there was quantitative
easing and they bailed out an 08
the money didn't go to the people the
money stopped at
the companies they're too big to fail
companies you didn't get the money
you didn't get the 600 no but the way
trump did quantitative easing
the money went to the people six hundred
dollars a week
which means even the unemployed had
money coming in
so it's not like it's a recession more
than when they were thinking
so you can't you can't say people
weren't spending money people are still
spending money people are still going
through the same you know similar things
that they were doing
because there was money still coming in
yes savings rate went up yes airlines
took ahead yes
hotels took it so this is not a typical
recession
now the other one is long-term economy
it's an opinion to say you don't think
the long-term economy is going to do
good
it's an opinion because right what did
he give the long-term economy to
he gave that to again okay now that's
clear bias
that's what i'm saying well i like his i
like his 13
markers i don't like the way he chose
his sides
what he should have done is he should
have said i'm bowing out of predicting
this year because it's too volatile
there's no way you can use this one no
he should say i'm
not how his guys makes his name he's not
happy no he doesn't want to sit this one
out he doesn't make his name at all
because
i agree with him you can't be a hundred
percent with this election
he was nope this is why here's what's
gonna happen this
i said can you look at debates as a
marker he says debates never mattered
hillary won every debate against trump
it was irrelevant trump still won he's
he said hillary won every debate against
trump is what his
his answer was and he's still one okay
see he tries to take
scientific theories and apply
unscientific answers to it because
how who there's no like final score in a
debate
i mean that is your own interpretation
right a debate could be looked at by 50
people and have 50 different answers
i i really think he should have just
said i'm not doing a prediction this
year and then retired
undefeated doesn't that make more sense
you know he was like
15. what's your beef with that i don't
have it but you're being you've got a
beef with liquid i don't have a beef at
all i just i don't buy into these
guys that that think that they're going
to use their formula and apply it to
this year because this is what happens
what happens and he's lucky like he
probably was on half of these because uh
part of it he's just guessing so
basically we don't even need to talk
about like
i tell you no i tell you i like the 13
markers yeah that's what i'm trying to
say
i do too i like the 13 markers but but
there's got to be a way
where you can reason and say you can't
tell me short-term economy not doing
good i think
what we've just established is okay we
like these 13. i like the market but
there's open for debate
yes you think he's not quite dramatic
well then talk about the other one
talk about the other one that he gave to
the democrats saying foreign military
successes
meaning he's had no military successes
he gave it to biden meaning
trump has had no military successes in
the last three and a half years i would
think that he hasn't had a major
military success however i do think he's
had significant
foreign success especially in the middle
east with obviously the um
the moving of the um uh embassy to
jerusalem
and then obviously everything that
happened with the uae uae like two weeks
25 years that's never whatever is
happening with china
visited north korea you got a guy that
takes a hassan soleimani
who was the number one terrorist in the
world you don't hear anything on the
news about isis when's the last time you
turned on the news and even thought
about isis
yeah when's the last time you watched
the news and you saw anything about isis
when's the last time it was done
three years ago what i'm trying to say
is do it now okay
what i'm trying to say is when's the
last time you even heard the word isis
why not so just because you don't hear
about it doesn't mean that it's not a
success
so i think this one can also be debated
on both sides tom what do you think well
don't
isn't the definition of not having or
couldn't you look at not having any
foreign success
in the military a good thing because he
hasn't had any altercations we didn't
lose any battles
we just didn't engage really and i think
eliminating isis is such a big deal
i mean that that was the number one news
story the number one world problem
probably in 2015 in 2014.
it was horrific what was going on and
now i don't think do they exist
i mean i hope we've completely
eradicated it i hope they're out
but i mean they've got a handle on it
all right and you got to get you got to
get some victories there
that's all i'm saying you got to give
some victories there i'm open to it
being 50 50.
on this one i'm not even saying it's on
trump or not i'm just saying
there can be an argument made for both
sides right
you have it nine nine four i have a nine
four i have it
uh i know you're you're dismissing this
you're you're you're zero and thirteen
and we already know i'm like
i'm like a las vegas
no no bet i have it actually in favor of
trump
um 7-6 oh so you have favor so let me
ask you which one flipped for you
i think whether you like trump or not
he's curious clearly i'm not a trump fan
he definitely has charisma okay so you
can't say he doesn't know then that's
the last one so when he gave it to
biden you're saying trump has yeah so
i'm flipping it now i disagree with you
on the short-term economy thing
the economy tell me why okay so a couple
different things
for the average american out there
things are not better than they were
four years ago
right now right now short term
average american you talked about the
pre-pre-covet or post coverage you're
talking about post coverage pre-covert
was it better or was it worse okay
we're talking short term terms last
three seconds was it better or worse
pre-covered like
january is it better or worse yes okay
so go to the term i'm giving
trump short term i'm not giving to trump
so long term you are giving it to trump
yes then it's eight five
so now we're eight five okay then that's
i think what he said
was the long-term ramifications i'm not
sure what he said
clearly the economy was booming under
trump no disagreement there that would
be the only
freaking reason i'd ever vote for trump
would be the economy
straight up um so i'm giving short term
not to trump i'm giving long term to
trump i'm flipping on the charisma i
disagree the guy is charismatic
um yeah i think that uh lickman
for i think the 13 points are a good
basis for a
discussion but they're not the gospel
here's one question
lickman gave long-term economy to biden
right
we all know what the tax increase we're
about to go into it yeah are going to be
how can any rational person you don't
have to be
a financial wizard to understand that
that's going to hurt the economy
well what he's saying is people he's not
giving it to biden what he's saying is
he's saying that the american people are
not optimistic about the future of the
economy that's what he's saying
so it's not necessarily saying hey
biden's going to make the economy better
he's just saying
the american people today are not
optimistic and i got no personal beef
against lichman i don't know who he is
but there was so much partisan
fervor going on in this country that his
his formula might not apply into one
i tell you i love his formula that's the
crazy thing like i walked away saying i
actually
like this because to me i'm a guy that i
like what the
what people said people said when i was
in miami i didn't speak in english i
went to school he says life was good and
then i took algebra and i said i have a
hard time figuring out letters and i
have to figure out letters and numbers
and they get together
i don't even know what the hell to do
right now right but
but i love formulas and this to me is
formula so to say
to say trump is not charismatic this is
what i told him here's my final thoughts
with him by the way
it seems like you guys are enjoying it
it's officially the biggest podcast
we've ever had on this new channel with
uh nearly 17 we brought to crack 17.
thank you guys
thumbs up and hit the subscribe button
but let's continue
the part about charisma this is what i
told them i said look my score
is nine four based on your markers i'm
giving
short term to trump i'm giving a long
term to trump
i'm giving foreign military to trump and
i'm giving
charisma to trump and and then i i made
my point i said the following so i have
nine four you have eight five
okay i said what's your favorite tv show
that you can watch over and over and
over again
he said i'm a yankees guy i said great i
said do you ever get tired of watching
yankees no i mean you watch yankees over
and over again that's great i'm a mickey
guy i told him about the mickey mental
car that i wanted etc etc
we had to laugh about it i said can you
imagine
a person to carry a show for 15 years
without charisma
i said it's mathematically impossible
before becoming a president
this guy had a tv show called apprentice
for 15 years because
americans left right middle wanted to
hear him say you're fired
they didn't give a [ __ ] if he's a
republican democrat or independent
matter of fact
when he had the apprentice show they
thought he was a democrat
so it's not about the politics he is
very
very charismatic and then i told him the
last thing i said look
alan how about this if you win
and biden wins i take you to yankees
game
third you tell me where you want to sit
four seats you take your family enjoy it
on the house
i said but if trump wins you come back
and say you're right i said how about
this
i'd like to see you get a double digit
streak to go into double digits like
your 10 is a big deal you got to have a
win streak
why don't you say right now and switch
to trump he said i can't do it so he
stuck to his guns and he's going with
biden
obviously we'll see what's going on she
had a really good conversation with you
i enjoyed him
sure and you know what kudos to him for
what he's done that is unbelievable not
many people can predict them
but do you think he would have been
getting the attention that he would be
right now about this if he had picked it
the other way
so this helps his brand going for biden
because he's going to get a lot of
positive
ideas i tell you one thing i tell you
one thing he says when he was working in
dc
and he said trump in 2016. he says i
lost a lot of friends
a lot of people were upset with me how
could you go against queen hillary
how can you go against the person that
everybody thought was going to be a
president by the way somebody
put a question here saying pat do you
really believe hillary won all three
debates i don't but he does he thought
he won
i think it was sheldon or something like
that i didn't think hillary wanted no no
pat here's another question i know you
like formulas but when
the person that runs the formula says i
lost a lot of friends because of my pick
and then the next time he does it he
does it the opposite way doesn't that
say it could be
potentially skewed no it could be it
totally could be that's what i'm saying
that's
that's why i was curious to know why he
went this direction with this and by the
way since we're already on this topic i
say we go into
biden's tax plan how about we talk about
biden's tax plan so check this out
last week i'm minding my own business
we're at our annual convention we're
preparing for we got a lot of stuff
going on
i get an email from goldman sachs from
advisor goldman sachs good people there
we like them a lot they do good for us
we every time we round them very very
helpful this is not an
article written by you know someone on
huffpost
this is not an article written by a
contributor on forbes
this is from goldman sachs talking about
biden's plan to prepare
ceos entrepreneurs business owners on
what is going to happen
when this takes place polls are trending
this is the email
polls are trending in the democratic
party's favor
and while polls are unreliable they have
fueled questions around what happens to
the financial markets
if the democrats take the white house
and or the senate
politics aside we are having
conversations with clients around what
if any steps we should take over the
next few months
a few topics of note are below let's go
through three of these topics with them
okay
together number one biden team
has published their tax plan and it
outlines increased corporate tax rate
personal income rates increase and
capital gains tax rates increasing
specifically the plan
outlines an increase in long-term
capital gains which is what anything
above one year so you buy some
i buy card for 500 000
i sell it two years later for a million
dollars the cap
for two million dollars the capital
gains taxes on that is what a million
and a half five hundred thousand
sell it for two million i'm paying
capital gains on that additional million
and a half i made
your cost basis tax-free 1.5 million yes
exactly
so the long-term capital gains taxes
from the current 20 is going to
39.6 so he's not taking it from 20
to 25 percent not 30 percent not 35
percent
to 39.6 it would be the highest capital
gains taxes
is what we're talking about nearly 2x
increase right that's number one
second is he talks about the current
gift
tax exclusion that stands at 11.4
million per person roughly 22 million
per couple
and you know they're thinking about that
this is going to go lower during obama
administration per person that was five
million dollars
it's supposed to expire by 2025 but he's
saying biden's probably gonna speed up
that process
and it's gonna bring you down to five
million sooner okay so this may not
apply to a lot of people that are
listening to this
but if you got money this applies to you
then you go a little bit deeper here
into the tax plan and here's what you
notice uh biden would raise corporate
tax rate from 21 to 28 percent
corporate tax rate that's seven
additional percent for corporate tax
rate
restore the top individual tax rate from
37 to 39.6 it went lower it's going to
go back to 39.6
uh tax plan would his tax bond would
raise between 3.35 trillion dollars to
3.67 trillion dollars over a decade
if enacted in full starting in 2021 okay
let me say that one more time
that means 3.35 trillion dollars of
american people is going to go to the
government that's really what that means
just so you know 3.35 trillion dollars
over a decade that's a lot of money
biden's tax plan is highly progressive
increasing taxes for the top 1
earners by 13 to 18 okay
and then continuously for people are at
the bottom like well pat i'm not really
affected by this this is just for the
rich people major proposals by biden's
campaign would raise 1.6 to 1.9 trillion
dollars over a decade from corporations
a trillion to a trillion to will come
from high earners from their income tax
800 billion to a trillion dollars from
social security taxes on highway earners
and then he's adding tax fees uh fees on
bank fees 100 billion dollars and a
bunch of other things that he's doing
meaning taxes are going up when i told
you the capital gains has gone from 20
to 39.6 adam what was your reaction to
it
you know that's pretty it's pretty
unbelievable like i said before the
um reason that i personally
would vote for trump is for the economy
you're being taxes this is the only
reason taxes only reason guy
money guy that that's i don't i don't
find him likable i don't find him
credible
uh but is it is it reason enough do you
think for people
for what people but like a lot of people
that maybe think that way
that think what way tom that financially
makes more sense with trump as president
i mean
rich people yeah rich people i doubt the
average working america is waiting would
you consider yourself a rich person i
would say that i am well off
yes i i would consider you well off but
yeah when i mean rich because sometimes
when you say rich nowadays
people think you're worth 100 million
you're still talking
one million you're still talking to the
people who make between a quarter
million to half a million dollar your
income
that's that's not what the average
american that's no no i'm not talking
about those people
you'd consider that rich though would
you say quarter million i would say that
you're wealthy you're doing what you're
welcome
you're making over two hundred thousand
dollars as a family 250 as a household
income
the average american household you know
how much the average american household
pulls in on average
63 000 okay so
we're talking middle america median
income people here they're not waking up
thinking
jesus these long-term capital gains i'm
not sure the estate tax
i don't know they might go from 20
million to 5 million the exemption yeah
most people don't think that way
obviously being around you thinking more
corporate thinking long-term capital
gain thinking about exit strategy
these are very pertinent items but
you know me being in the insurance
business life settlement business
understanding long-term capital gain
this is some scary stuff guys
so for people that are paying attention
to taxes if the highest
long-term cane long-term tax gain
is 15 20 percent you're going to double
it to the to the highest ordinary uh
income tax number 39.6 is scary stuff
but big picture i'm not even talking
trump i'm not even talking biden i'm
talking
10 20 30 years down the road what have
you taxes are going to increase in this
country
back when uh reagan was an actor do you
know reagan's story about when he was a
actor president of sag or which which
story when he was a actor the tag you
know what the top tax rate was this is
1930s
90 freaking percent in america yes
when i saw that i'm like what country
was this in yes so reagan would say he
would make two movies a year
because if he made a third movie he
would make way too much money and get to
get taxed sure at 90 so this is some of
the stuff he was brilliant tax strategy
obviously i'm making
i'm making uh two movies a year because
if i make third they're taking 90
percent of it
so this is scary stuff but whether it's
15 20
39 this is really aggressive taxes are
going up in this country this is a
conversation we're going to have
for the upcoming decades for sure
especially with our unfunded liabilities
with social security
medicare medicaid everything that's
going on with the the deficit
with uh the um the debt calculator
scary stuff um this is going to be an
ongoing debate but i think this is
obviously going to affect anybody who's
wealthy
long-term capital gain the average
american i don't think they think about
it i think
i think one thing that would help biden
if he said okay these tax increases are
going towards
infrastructure or some things that all
they're saying is it's 3.6 trillion
dollars so where is it going
uh vaporizing i mean is it going to
knock down the national debt i mean
that's the big question what do you i
mean
is it going to go to programs that maybe
people don't support right which is
another political issue
but that's a lot of money that's 300
plus billions here's here's the simplest
way i look at it
adam and i hope this helps you out and
this kind of makes sense to you
in life i look at everybody as an
advisor okay
advancement investment advisor is that
three trillion dollars
better in the private with entrepreneurs
taking that three trillion and doubling
to six trillion twelve trillion twenty
four trillion dollars
or is that three trillion better being
given to politicians
on what they can do better with that
three trillion option a that's my point
to you so
today by the way for the listener that's
listening to this here's what you have
to realize
uh uh adam is it fair to say you've
never voted for a republican president
for a republican president did i vote
for
bush and against kerry i don't think i
voted for republican president
okay you've never voted for a republican
president so so
you're somebody that you would say
socially you're left
an economic 40-yard line okay you're on
a 40-yard line yes fair enough okay
but economically you're concerned i'm on
the other side that's right
so this is the challenge if you remember
when we were talking
sometime last year and people were
asking me hey what could happen
not even last year just like five months
ago what could happen for trump to
lose the election i said if the dao
stays and goes to 18th out he ain't
getting reelected
period he ain't getting re-elected one
of the biggest mistakes
democrats did believe it or not you know
what they did
when coronavirus took place they had a
four-month period
to really show fear in america they
should have never
send the 600 to the american people per
week
the moment they agreed to do that trump
became the good guy
he took care of the people in their
hearts the american people said man
crisis happened
so it backfired on democrats
because they wanted to do that but it
happened during the trump administration
forever that credit's going to go to
trump because they're going to remember
the president 30 years from now no one's
going to remember that who came up with
this
600 a week when they came up with that
600 a week it brought the dow
from 1890 that went to just a few months
ago
to 29 000 if the economy is at 29 000
most of the time the american people are
like you know what if the economy's fine
the unemployment for african-americans
spanx as low as it's ever been
i'm just going to keep it the way it is
right now i think it kind of is going to
backfire on democrats that's my thoughts
well and
the number one thing i equate with the
taxes going higher
corporation tax going up is uh layoffs
right and more people i think
thinking long term how's this going to
affect their jobs so
i don't know it's uh when they did they
did they put any bias in the email when
they reached out to you did they give
you any advice with it or is that their
job
the guy's a stat he's a step but to be
fair the the chief economist
of uh um of uh goldman sachs
is a persian lady and i had a chance to
go listen to her earlier this year in
february
when chronovirus was just coming up and
they said at that time that they weren't
too concerned about chronovirus i don't
know if you remember the reports kai we
read that extensively when they give me
the reports like 50 page report
chronovirus wasn't a big deal to them
didn't think was going to be as big as
it ended up being
and she doesn't necessarily favor trump
a lot of the people like goldman sachs
don't necessarily favor trump so they're
going to be more left-leaning from the
chief economist standpoint
and a lot of times when you get this
email the email is coming from the chief
economist giving it to the next person
and the next person
and then it's coming up so the leaning
is a left-leaning uh uh
of policies that they have from the top
not necessarily him
but the economy is coming from the top
but you know let's go to a couple other
topics here again we're going to find
out what's going to happen here all i'm
saying is
if it goes like this and the 39.6
is what biden's tax plan is going to be
for capital gains you're going to have
second thoughts about voting for biden
that's what you're saying
i'm just saying that's the only reason i
would consider
not so if today's the day to vote you go
to the booth
what are you doing what's what does josh
weigh today what does josh wait today
because we have a bet
josh if you're listening i love you
buddy that bet is still in place buddy
i want you losing weight all right so
just to wrap this up we you have uh
nine four i have nine four uh trump you
got eight five i think i had
seven six eight five and tom our good
friend over here has got zero thirteen
he thinks he's a quack given no i say
you just don't do with the formula in
2020. okay
it's different the show goes on baby by
the way the show goes up i asked him i
said has anybody ever won a sweep 13-0
and the way you guys did it from 1860 to
today he says only one
i said who he said teddy roosevelt wow
teddy roosevelt's the only one that won
yeah that's right was the only one that
won 13-0 anyways let's let's talk a
little business
let's talk a little business here so
amazon this is really apparently
happening i thought this was not going
to happen anytime soon but it's
apparently happening so
amazon announces their drone program
that it's ready for liftoff amazon
received its faa certificate that will
allow it to move forward with drone
delivery
the drone program in 2013 was first
announced and ever since then that
they've been working on it the mk27
drones
will be able to fly up to 15 miles
and deliver packages weighing less than
five pounds
in less than 30 minutes can you show us
the picture of this guy so we can kind
of see this
so so if it's less than 15 miles i order
something on amazon
it's less than five pounds within 30
minutes it's a
it arrives to my house it's crazy stuff
when you think about it yeah it's very
crazy i mean
all i think about is imagine how many
people are ordering stuff on amazon
how many drones are we going to see no
kidding because you're seeing them drop
one box i mean look there's so many
amazon vans on the street have you
noticed they're
everywhere everywhere they're everywhere
is there something to see or no let's
see what this looks like
so that's apparently the drone
[Music]
can you make that bigger for us to see
or
[Music]
safety and fishing delivery packages to
customers
[Music]
this is spam you know what with the
volume of packages they deliver
i don't know how this makes a dent how
how can dropping off one package
15 miles away is it is it is this more
for publicity
i tell you within 30 minutes tom you buy
i mean we have an amazon down the street
here less than 30 miles away you know
which one i'm talking about
on the way to the freeway you ever seen
that one it's a massive ship right side
right no no i think it's great i mean if
they could do it but what if everybody
in this room ordered something right now
would there be eight uh drones in the
air
trapping them over the building right
now that's what they're saying what
about the other 500
000 people in dallas that are ordering
at the same time but that's what i'm
saying if they have
i mean you're going to look at the sky
i'm just i'm just visualizing you look
up
600 drones above you well no kidding it
just looks clear what about ups
and fedex won't they want to do the same
thing won't that help them
as well it is unbelievable i i can't
imagine that this takes off
i can't i mean i was a huge fan of the
movie back to the future right i know
obviously sometimes
for fun you dress up as doc brown just
for i did yes
for for good times um shout out to uh
john mason he's marty mcfly in his spare
time
um but i'm a huge fan of that but what a
twist what a plot twist we've had in the
world
we thought years ago we'd have flying
cars
that would be happening in 2020. now we
have flying drones delivering your
toilet paper
because you don't want to go to the
store by the way have you it's a sad
situation
have you heard what the usps is doing
for to combat this with their latest
technology
they're going to put every letter into a
paper airplane and then zip it over to
your house
forget drones man they're going to make
paper airplanes that's their new
delivery service well i can see that
that's what the government would do if
they wanted to do something your mail-in
ballot right there i tell you this is
going to be
i cannot so are we a fan of this are we
not a fan is this good is this bad is
this stupid this is i don't know
what question is if it were a fan of it
or not i think the question is is it
happening going on and do you have any
say in it
i think it's happening yeah i'm a fan of
it for one reason
my 14 year old daughter whenever she
orders something on amazon she's bombing
me with text all day
go get my package go get my package you
know this might get it there quicker
fewer texts i tell you remind so imagine
you are
you know a 12 year old boy okay and and
you figure out the bb gun
you take it out you go in the backyard
you're seeing drones being delivered and
they're coming
lower and lower and lower you're like
playing target practice i mean the 12
year is what they're gonna be people are
getting
shots they can of course shooting pieces
for sure that's the part you're gonna
see
boxes falling what if one of the drones
like you know has a
challenge it comes down crash in the
middle of the freeway it's gonna be very
entertaining weather
i mean thunderstorms at dallas how do
these things fly thanks boom
drone gets hit i'm gonna sound i'm gonna
sound like an old grumpy man right now
and you're talking to somebody
that would work from home doesn't have a
car uber's everywhere
doesn't go shopping does instacart i
don't i don't go to the i don't go to
the walmart i'll go i'll order
amazon like i'm as like techy as it gets
but we're gonna have a new generation
your kids your kids
that are not gonna under my kids when i
got you know knock on wood ladies
out there i'm single um the instant
gratification thing
is on overload right now imagine you
just
where's my package it's been 31 minutes
like this ain't a freaking pizza bro
like there's certain things good things
take time
i'm not saying that everything that
you're ordering but the instant
gratification of everything you order
30 minutes 30 minutes 30 minutes is a
freaking drone this i gotta have my my
video game where is it come on
like this is a little this is getting a
little aggressive guys the
differentiator could
it might be pay an extra two hundred
dollars that's when you're rich when
you're rich you do what adam just you
just throw money
right do you think maybe if the option
is you're paying attention to 300
you get the drone service because
there's just no way for the sheer volume
of packages they deliver
you can have drones dropping them off
but i really i mean i think it's
fascinating
what how did amazon deliver the packages
two three years ago
because you didn't see amazon vans are
they just more comfortable having their
own vans out there they had stealth vans
they had rape
unmarked vans just i mean they're
everywhere and then it's fascinating
when you see the little areas where
they'll
park them like i i see little hotels you
know throughout
la where there's 50 amazon vans i mean
so they have
they must have so many trucks out there
listen just just know
that jeff bezos was so good that his
wife's wealth
doubled in the last couple months she's
now worth 68 billion dollars richest
ex-wife
richest woman in the world okay can you
imagine how powerful you are you're
you're worth 200 million and your
ex-wife is worth 68 billion
you are not only the richest man in the
world right you your wife your ex-wife
is the richest woman in the world that's
ridiculous that's what that means
uh and i don't think amazon is slowing
down anytime soon by the way so again
shout out to jeff bezos man you and your
drones it is what it is so
uh a zoom ceo eric wan uh
6.6 billion dollars he made in one day
let me say that one more time he made
6.6 billion dollars in one day
uh i think their zoom is now bigger than
starbucks it's bigger than a lot of
these companies that you read about
and their stocks skyrocketed the
question now is
did people listening to this did anybody
listen to today's podcast buy any zoom
stock or own any zoom stock
pre pre march first if you did own
zoom stock pre-march first you're
probably bragging about it
your friend these are the moments that
you can brag about these types of things
if you own zoom stock pre-march first
do you think zoom is going to slow down
anytime soon
um well the brand awareness is out there
and everybody's going to use it now the
question is
kids are going to go back to school we
hope eventually so fewer uses there
will people go back to the office so yes
i think just sheer volume it'll have to
go down
by total number of people using it but
man they've uh they they've entered the
uh the playing field
pretty dramatically here i don't know
yeah i mean no no
great great point um we've learned you
know a couple key terms that we've
learned
or over the last six months social
distancing that was a word we've never
used face masks and then essential
right essentials zoom has
taken the word essential and brought it
to different levels this
zoom has been essential pat just did the
most ridiculous event
php just did the most ridiculous event
all
via zoom you usually do it in las vegas
you're taking over mgm
10 000 people absolute chaos pandemonium
you did it with 10 people in a freaking
room you have general mattis you got
trey gowdy you got daley daley
missed a worldwide pitbull all via zoom
and it was it was an incredible event i
mean what an event what a time what a
place to be alive
via zoom in it all happened via zoom do
you know do you know what feedback we
got so we
every time we do this we send an email
out and we get a survey back
we said we had a two-hour meeting
yesterday to read every single survey
you know what the survey was craziest
survey the survey was
they were able to connect with the
speakers better because they looked at
them on their camera
so they're watching them here versus
that convention you're watching them
that's a hundred yards away because you
got a bunch of people in the room so
so the connection with seeing their
faces
was closer to them how weird is it to
say i connected
and you know what else alan lichtman
said yesterday which was interesting
he says you ever been to an rnc or dnc
convention he says when you go to rnc
and dnc convention
he says you don't hear any of the
speakers he says all it is is the entire
time delegates are walking around it's
loud it's noisy it's distractions it's
this
he says here's the one thing about this
year's dnc and rnc you were able to
listen to
every one of the speakers there was no
distractions it was just straight up
talking to you
so there was nothing being said that you
didn't catch so i think this zoom thing
with the direction we're going in right
now
i don't think this is going away i don't
think this is a model that's going away
and i think if they add a couple
gamification models to it
and they decide to come out with a
social side to it i think this
zoom thing can keep growing two points
um lickman's right about one thing
because the speakers
were so much more impactful because they
weren't having the reporters
on the floor interviewing the delegates
right those dopey delegates that come in
from all over the country
that's the most obnoxious thing about
the convention so the speakers were a
lot more impactful
is there going to be a competitor to
zoom can google step up and and really
take them on and have a device
well webex had the lead yeah but they
didn't have enough infrastructure to be
able to handle we kept using webex webex
webex
three times it crashed on us and i said
i'm done with webex we left cisco we
went to zoom yeah zoom had a big crash
last week that
they made big news now here's the other
thing that's fascinating most people say
i never really even heard of zoom
you know until covet hit but this guy
was a billionaire before covent
his net worth now the ceo was 23 billion
it went up six so he already was a
billionaire
so apparently zoom was making an impact
on someone did you see that the primary
chinese investor
he has like nine percent and uh he's
worth 11 billion because of zuma now
unbelievable can you imagine you know
the ceo's name now
john eric eric yeah
um two things with that just to follow
up we talked about this
initially i think you know five six
months ago yeah just being ready for the
moment
you know zoom didn't say well hold on
guys we'll get right with you
we got a couple glitches they were ready
i mean corona hit boom zoom entered the
equation just talking about being ready
but the one thing and this is kind of
shifting topics here is i read that
letter
that seinfeld wrote about new york yeah
and
one thing that stuck out to me we're
talking about zooming pull up the
seinfeld letter
we're talking about zoom we're talking
about remote we're talking about logging
in we're talking about you know
all that fun stuff something that
seinfeld just you know people are
calling for the death of new york city
yeah
you know nothing beats just real-life
human interaction could you imagine if
we were doing this
and it was all via zoom yeah maybe
people get you know different experience
but there is something special about
sitting in a room being with people
like let's not forget about that as
amazing as zoom is nothing beats human
interaction i don't disagree
i don't disagree at all but i think the
speed of delivery and messaging
and how you can conduct now business
internationally through
zoom i i just don't think this is going
away i think people
no doubt no doubt it's not going away
look
we grew got 174 percent we grew
july to july if you take zoom out we're
not growing 174
how the hell do we grow 174 july to july
zuma's got a lot to do with it and
you're hearing a lot of success stories
with other people
that are doing the same thing as well by
the way joe wrote into spotify you guys
heard about what happened when he went
to spotify
did you guys hear about what happened
with spotify so rogan goes to spotify
okay this was last week kai keeps
reminding me hey he's leaving he's
leaving he's leaving
and he even showed me his new set which
is sick i don't know if you've seen his
news said rogan's new set
really cool new set if you want to put
it up and show it up guys yeah i like i
love his new set he's got
uh obviously it's here in austin isn't
it the new suppressed images let's see
if
uh images
uh right there that's one that's second
uh right there
so that's kind of how they're putting
this set together it's not over with yet
obviously they have the new one you can
see i think on his instagram post
but that's kind of what they're putting
together pretty cool what they're doing
that is austin
nice as big as i thought it would be
let's well it's very creative
it's creative television but go to the
go to the data that came back about his
podcast on spotify
so it's it came back the full list of
missing episodes on spotify
okay owen smith a bunch of different
names alex jones is missing
okay you got uh um uh
gavin mcginnis is missing uh alex
johnson eddie bravo is missing milo
yiannopoulos is missing
another gavin mcguinness is missing
another milo is missing christine did
you see that that's right that's right
so adam bravo adam sometimes talk about
conspiracy theories he's missing
dave asprey is missing you you got a lot
of people that's missing you know
huh steve grier what's the what's the
theme here though
uh i i'm i am hopeful
that rogan's attorneys when they did
this contract they did it in a way where
rogan was free
to keep all the things that he talks
about on because
if they control him i don't think
rogan's the kind of guy that's going to
be okay with that
i just don't think it's going to work
out with rope but you cannot put a
tasmanian devil in a cage you cannot do
that with a guy like that rogan's got
opinions he's going to get his opinions
i mean his deal was 100 million it's not
like he wasn't making a lot of money or
he probably could have made close to
that did you remember what bill simmons
from espn then he started the ringer you
know what he sold for
to spotify 200 million 200 million
he had a network of podcasts through the
ringer so there was multiple and he had
a lot of people but yeah
he made 200 million dollars one of the
most annoying guys in sports by the way
bill simmons
very annoying but he people really
though no no one's i didn't say he's not
brilliant why is he annoying
because what i mean by you know is not
from my end sports people in sports
get annoyed by bill simmons because he
says the most random things
okay and he sticks to it and half the
time he's wrong
half the time that's what i've realized
with bill simmons that's bill yeah i
guarantee that this was gonna happen
but guess who else does that charles
barkley does that oh you know
sweet oh yeah would you see him mopping
forward and then the thing about bill
you know bill started as the sports guy
in boston so he did a yahoo.com blog
right so he was the anti-media guy
because i was working in boston at the
time at fox and
he hated on on air tv people he was
always ripping us and just making fun of
us
in his blog he had a cult like following
then he went to espn
you know people loved him for his
writing and then now he was ahead of the
game though i got to give him credit in
he understood what was going on with the
blah or with the the podcast and really
got it going at espn and then when he
started the ringer that was the main
part of their business i think
the print or the online version of the
articles is just you know to support it
but 200 mil but you know i guess you
need a deep dive to just see what
everybody was talking about here on
these episodes with with roger but
there's nothing he wouldn't know
going into this new deal with spotify
right the deal you know i'm a little
concerned about that because
i don't know about not keeping those on
those are some of the best ones he's
done that the viewers were talking about
you're going to take those off because
he's contra they took off the one where
joey diaz says what he used to do with
comedians back in the days i don't know
if you've heard
about female ladies say you'd come and
do this and you get 10 minutes to talk
and
they took that one down here is he they
took off the controversial stuff this
isn't a left or right thing
right you got nick kroll on there who's
a liberal hollywood you know actor
so you know you've got um
jordan peterson i think they took off as
well joey diaz comedian i don't think
this is a political thing but i think
it's just a controversial thing they
don't want
well that's the whole thing though yeah
exactly but that's the whole thing
so you can't create controversial
content on spotify
then is that what spotify's brandon
itself has sure you cannot just talk
about anything on spotify and they're
going to be forced now to answer this
question don't you think yeah
they have to have some sort of statement
i think they would what does it say on
the top right
rogan's podcast is moving exclusive
spotify after signing 100 million
deal and his fans are not happy about
what episodes are being left
behind during the transition just to be
clear we're not going to see
any rogan on youtube moving forward only
short clips based on what kai's telling
me
it's gonna be a segway from like it's
still apparently on youtube but then
it's gonna be a segue but
by the end of the year i heard the last
december it goes 100
spotify meaning you're not going to find
him at all
only ads but it's 100 on spotify by the
way the one thing i like about spotify
that
you know i hope youtube does this i kind
of like the 3.0 speed that they have
some people can't listen to stuff 3.0
speed and spotify has three points 3.0
pat
you know a logical reason these aren't
there yeah i mean possibly maybe rogan
couldn't afford those u-haul charges
and get that extra truck to move out of
california to texas
so he had to leave those tapes you got
to give all the credit back to or news
governor knew something i mean you know
when you're that special you're that
special you know you have a whole
did you answer the chances that you're
leaving california i think we skipped
over that what are the chances you're
leaving california it it's painful to
think about because california you know
is a place that people love when they're
there
listen what about you i'm keeping all my
options open
he said slim to none what are the
chances you're leaving california good
good eventually yeah probably yeah
you're going to leave california
you know there's a good chance i mean
who knows but it would have been a firm
and emphatic
no five months ago 100 percent no no way
ever yeah yeah never nothing with
driving out of california
so the coronavirus exposed a lot of
people five months ago i'm going to cal
did you hear about what happened with
the church who's that one pastor uh
macarthur macarthur uh john mcarthur
who's uh
uh the big pastor in life he can look
him up he's been they've been leasing
their church from la county for 45 years
okay and so they did their service i
just type in macarthur
type in macarthur macarthur you were in
the right direction macarthur
t-h-u-r kai t-h-u-r
oh my gosh kai just type in
you had it macarthur pastor la
la okay there we go then go to news
go to news top the go news
and joe pandemic number example got it
okay here's what happened
mayor garcetti you know what they're
doing so he opened up his church and he
says you can't do anything with me on
the church i can open up and
have my uh members come in and see this
he goes
against all the laws of california and
he says you cannot tell me not to do
this
they've had a 45-year lease in la
and you know what garcity does they're
not canceling his
lease and they took away his parking
spots
so members couldn't go there and they
said you don't have the lease anymore
so they took it away from them this is
ugly stuff this is ugly stuff and that's
what california is doing and
you know they think they can get away
with it the best part about competition
is i love that
this is happening because when you are
number one okay
california says we are the five number
five economy in the world that said
when you become number one couple things
follow when you become number one if
you're not too careful
arrogance you think you're untouchable
comes and anytime you act arrogant
pompous and you think you're untouchable
you officially have a target on you from
many people competition that's what's
happened with california right now
people going to be
exploiting that nonstop by the way some
bad news for you i don't know if you've
heard about the battle there's always
bad news for you here's
what the [ __ ] is that did you guys hear
about this paul's not going to like this
too much paulie's going to be furious
about this
moving forward pakistan is no longer
accepting
dating apps like tinder and grinder it's
done so
paul e is done paulie if you're
listening pakistan
no more grinder no more down the pizza
paul put down the patio gear
the grinder well i'm worried about that
guy and on top of that this is one of
the things i'm very proud of india
i am so excited about india we just
hired a couple more
indian uh engineers here from india one
of them uh lived in the slums of india
she's not working with us
she's a beast and the other analysts we
had they're both beasts i've seen them
quality quality guys india bands
118 chinese apps
flat out bands okay 118
apps india bands india is publicly just
saying
we don't want to have anything to do
with you
wechat you know wechat you ever heard of
wechat no longer in
india they banned 118
uh uh chinese apps and a statement made
issued by uh india's ministry of
electronics and information technology
he said
this decision is a targeted move to
ensure safety security and sovereignty
of indian cyberspace
what a thing to do and what a thing to
say do you think
india's trying to say we're not afraid
of china we want to compete
and do something and take over china i
don't know it's gonna be a lot of work
for them to do that
but they're headed in the right
direction shout out to india sure i
think they're basically saying we're
skeptical of any
chinese app that's probably stealing our
data spying on us and we're not going to
give them that advantage anymore
right wipe it out what do you do you
take it as a message or do you just take
it out they're just trying to make sure
cyberspace is good
no no it's a message i think it's all
the above
if there's one thing i know about
patrick bet david there's one thing i
know
here we go he wants to push back against
china here we go i mean
am i wrong on that i mean you think
china is coming for america clearly
this is your other than taxes these days
other than potential exit taxes
china number one on your agenda let me
ask you and i don't disagree with that
okay
okay i know you were going with that
yeah i agree with you on that
but am i wrong in saying that no i don't
absolutely not
okay so you like this when you see news
like this you like this i
love the fact that india's not afraid
yes
i love the fact that india is not afraid
and they're making a statement that's
what i love about what india is doing
right now i love the fact that they're
not afraid and they're saying you know
what the hell with you here's what we're
doing we're not okay with this
we're not okay what you're doing there's
no way in the world we're gonna support
something like this i don't know
i'm all for it i like the fact that
they're you know standing strong to
china and they're not scared of them you
mentioned the other day you know
obviously you lean a little bit
pro capitalism pro-right on the on the
agenda i am 100 percent
capitalist 100 everything else i'm open
to debating clearly 100
cash and i brought up the other day you
said whoever's tougher on china is who i
would vote for so i gave an example i
said you know on the democratic side
yes if you have tulsi gabbard on the
left hypothetically everybody
hypothetically
on the democratic side and you have
someone like john kasich on the right
who's a little bit more moderate um you
would vote for the democrat who is
harder on china
stricter on china than a republican
there's no question about
it tell me about tell me about that if
tulsi gabbard is running
against kasich say kasich's the
republican nominee and tulsi gabbard is
the democratic nominee
so here's a uh woman who has served in
the military i think 16 years and she's
been around for
a while even though she's younger she's
got she's energetic 39 years old 39
years old but it wasn't a military she
served
and hillary can't stand her which is a
big sign for republicans
because hillary and her went into the
biggest feud i don't know if you
remember this where she said she
was owned by russia she's owned by
russia and her famous line and all this
stuff the person who's owned by russia
claims everybody else is owned by russia
it's so interesting when people make
comments like that well she would
probably know
she would probably know and tulsi is
like wait a minute and tulsi
came back the next day and boom her
video went off
got back millions of views i like
tulsi's uh
you know she's got a backbone she's
strong and if she's against china going
against kasich and kasich says
let's make china work and drop the
tariffs yeah i'm probably going to lose
china though at this point who's like
not about pro china it's who is
who is for sale this is not about who's
pro china
who's for sale because china is willing
to buy
look when biden wanted to
when years ago biden voted to bring
china in the world trade organization
why would you bring china into the world
trade organization
while they're doing everything they can
to take all your inventory and your
technology and all your
patents away from you what do you mean
bring them into the world trade
organization and get away with crime
who the hell would want to bring
somebody like china into the world trade
organization
they're not friends and allies with you
they're not on your side they don't
think the way you do
they simply want to take everything from
you and be held accountable for nothing
so buy them voted for i mean yeah of
course if
when you're saying who is for china it's
not about who is for china
it's about when you go into the
negotiation room
and the doors are closed who do i trust
in that room
because when you go into the negotiation
the cameras are not there
i don't see the cameras who who's going
to be pushing them
and when you come out of the meeting you
watch to see who's upset
if you come out at a meeting and you see
china's got the biggest smile on their
face
guess what that means they got what they
wanted if china comes out
and they're angry at trump okay good i
kind of like that a little bit
because the deal's probably not
happening because he's not giving up the
tariffs
so it's not about who's for china who's
not it's who doesn't have the backbone
to go and stand up against a regime that
powerful that just invested 400 billion
dollars into iran
that is doing an economic hitman job on
africa
that is buying up land to own africa
that is buying a pr
illand to own iran china china wants to
indirectly own the oil in iran
people are not seeing this stuff this
this stuff that's taking place i had a
conversation
i don't know if i told you guys on the
podcast i don't think i told him on the
part because i had a call last week with
a very
powerful military general did i tell you
about the story or not i don't know
very uh uh private uh uh how should i
put this private conversation with a
very powerful
uh general from shaw's military okay
he's in his 80s we had a very strong
conversation together last week
and we talked about what are your
thoughts about china investing 400
billion
in iran he says if iranian people don't
understand and do something about this
and turn this down
iran's going to be owned by china for
the next few decades
just like how uk owned iran for decades
when they first had that oil company
that was owned by uk and eventually opec
you know this whole thing became british
petroleum and you know all that stuff
started with a partnership of iran yeah
i don't trust anybody that can be bought
and is for sale with china and what can
the iranian people even do though
what can the iranian people do what do
you mean what kind of iranian people
meaning there's got to such a protest
protest protest protest protest protest
has that led to in iran it led to a
revolution in 1979 i'm saying recently
nine no what i'm saying to you is in
1970 1979 if you didn't want the shot he
left
if you got that kind of a backbone once
you do it again well didn't they try to
do that somewhat recently
yes and what happened and it wasn't no
they stopped
they tried to do an stop right and but
here's the other part
i believe if they do it this time iran
and they continue i do believe trump
will help them
because i don't think trump is okay with
china trying to own iran
i don't think so and i think trump will
support the iranian people
the iranian people not with the
government why would the regime
like just think about it from the regime
whether what are they thinking when
they're accepting 400
billion dollars what what's the term for
sale okay buddy you
are for sale if you're taking 400
billion dollars from china you're
telling your people of iran
you're for sale how are they spending it
to the people i don't know i'm not up on
iranian politics how are they
it's very easy how you spin it to people
okay remember when we had naomi uh
park on a couple weeks ago and she did
the interview she's the one that escaped
north korea went to china
she was bought as a virgin for 200
eventually went to south korea and
came over here gave a talk at 50 million
views in 24 hours crazy
and she's going to be here today we're
going to have lunch with her today by
the way you guys will get a chance to
meet her she's gonna be here today
and uh we're gonna we're gonna
potentially do some kind of
collaborations with her but i'm excited
about her being here today
so when i was talking to her and
i said so tell me why is north korea
able to do what they're doing right now
i said who has north korea's back china
china
so let me get this straight the same
country that invested
in iran 400 billion dollars has north
korea's
back wait what yeah right
you have north korea's back
and you invest into iran and the iranian
government is willing to
accept 400 billion dollars yeah and
that's the price
and then did you see how china has is
going to double their nuclear arsenal
in the next few years north korea just
said the same thing you know
do the iranian people have the ability
to pull it off though
as ruthless as that regime is and to to
whatever levels they would
squash it they do no no no it's not
about i don't think they do listen
never underestimate the power of people
i need battery here never understand
underestimate the power and they would
need the full support of the us which
they potentially could get
under trump they would not on the under
under biden they would not but under
trump they would so
you know that that when you talk in
china that's where i go with china you
got to be very very careful with china
you got to keep an eye out again
goes back to the same thing russia told
you they're tough guys and don't mess
with them
china doesn't tell you china uses props
you got to be careful with that by the
way a couple things with sports
zlatan whom i'm a very big fan of if
you've not watched this documentary
you've got to watch it he's going back
he's going back to ac milan uh by the
way one of the coolest things in the
documentary i was telling you about to
watch this kid is 16 17 years old
yeah he's going with his agent his
manager who's in his late 40s early 50s
to sign a contract
his manager is nervous before signing
the contract
and he tells his manager this 17 year
old kid says won't you act like you've
been here before
calm down bro you know that that's the
it factor right i mean he how are you
kidding me why don't you act like you've
been here before
and and the manager listened to him
right he like minded him
and by the way i know messi said he's
leaving he wants to go to manchester
there's a lot of stuff going on
nba you had chris paul and them lost
with the whole
referee delay of game you had the other
side
the bucks are down too so
very weird advances with two points yeah
interesting things going on denver
series we won't go too deep in sports
while we're gonna
well people lose all our listeners but
you know what for you you've been in the
sports world your entire career pretty
much you did some stuff with jordan
when you were covering the bulls how was
it working with michael jordan it was
unbelievable
really i mean uh to this day i mean
there's never
anything i could do that will cap that
or do
anything and then just watching the last
dance it was crazy because i was in the
middle of all that for three years
i arrived in chicago when i was working
for nbc the day rodman did
basically so the first thing i did was
cover that press conference so it was
unbelievable
um craziest story give us a crazy story
you know what it's just
because i worked for the nbc station you
know we were able to be around the bulls
even more
because the games were on our channel
you know just being able to interact
with michael
in in times that you wanted and people
go what's he like i mean he is literally
amazingly cool i mean i think that came
across in the documentary that
that he's nice to people he dealt with
the media he cared i mean clearly it was
all because social media wasn't there
but
we also hosted a show on sunday nights
with dennis rodman
okay which was probably the number one
show in chicago every sunday night
uh after the ten o'clock news and rodman
would come on these shows
um you know drunk okay oh so
okay so all of the above
so you you'd know rodman was there
because you could smell
beni hana in the building so he would
come from benihana him and carmen
electra they would do their thing after
a game
so we would do it in may right that's
when the shows would be live
uh we used to do it at michael jordan's
restaurant so rodman would show up he'd
smell betty hannah
he'd drop his wallet and you'd see all
his cash he'd throw it on the table
and then he go do his do his appearances
i mean just some random stories about
him just go you know we had the
opportunity to go out with him
you know party with robin he would drink
kamikazes by the dozen
and just pound them he'd order him by
the dozen he'd stack him up
he'd crush him he'd be out until 3 a.m
and then he'd make practice
so we used to do the show live at dinner
at michael jordan's restaurant and this
is in may during sweeps
right where you try to save your best
best shows and craziest i saw jenny
mccarthy was at the bowls game that
afternoon right they were playing they
were playing the heat in the playoffs
and i saw janet go jenny once you come
by michael jordan's restaurant tonight
you know we'll do the show okay all
right you know that's what she was doing
that nbc
sitcom that she had so what happened was
the nba playoffs got pushed a little bit
late that day so our show didn't start
till 11.
that meant rodman could drink more okay
so he shows
up he shows up at michael jordan's
restaurant in a chicago police officer
uniform with his hands handcuffed to
himself
now the other funny thing is jay leno
was in town doing his shows live in
chicago at the state theater the whole
week so we had him
on the show that night too so rodman did
the whole show
with his hands handcuffed to himself so
as they were about to start the show the
florida and this is a live audience at
michael jordan's restaurant
if this story gets boring tell me but he
uh they start doing the countdown
five okay guys you're on to five four
rodman turns up
turns out he goes bro i am so effing
wasted
except he used the word that's what he
said right and you're live
so then the show starts he starts
talking trash about pat riley doing this
and that
we had jenny mccarthy on there he was
doing some inappropriate things but at
the end of the show we brought jay leno
out
because it was his birthday so we took
this big sheet cake we got for him
and leno stuck his face in it and goes
like that right and then rodman did the
same thing
so robin sticks his face in the cake
does this and then falls back
all of a sudden you hear all these
glasses shatter he broke we broke like
20 wine glasses
at michael jordan's restaurant needless
to say the next week we were doing the
show at planet hollywood
no more jordan typical tuesday night
dennis rodman
just last week while we're doing our
conference ricky is here ricky says hey
my cousin was at a nightclub this last
weekend look who she who look who was at
the nightclub i said who
shows me a picture rodman getting
hammered just last week
robin's uniform can i tell you one
rodney's story and i got a picture to
back it up so
my son who was six years old at the time
was obsessed with the bulls because he
knew i worked there and he just loved
everything about michael
you played that song adam right then for
the bulls intro so my son got down
the perfect ray clay impersonation at
six years old
and now the starting lineup for chicago
right so he did that you know with that
song in the background
so we were staying at a hotel in newport
and my son goes hey
do you think we'll see any celebrities
like who knows who knows dash uh you
know kobe lives here you never know who
running here robin's around here
i'm checking in my wife is around the
corner she goes you never believe who's
here
rodman so he walked through robin was
staying because robin lived in newport
he you'd always see him in orange yeah i
know exactly where he lived in newport
okay so
we were staying at the island hotel i go
well let's go see robin let's go see him
we check in
and it was 11 o'clock in the morning
maybe 11 30. and we go back by the pool
and in this back room
he's sitting at this private table with
four cougars for lack of a better word
loving everything that he was saying
he's laughing at everything he said
i go back there and he was probably a
little tip saying oh dennis hey
hey i want to say hi my son's this is
dash man life's a laker hat
um so we go hey dance remember chicago
back in the day i think he kind of
remembered or whatever
so all of a sudden i go hey dennis my
son can do the uh the bulls
impersonation of ray clay doing it he
goes plate i had the song on my phone so
we do it
and then my son does the whole thing and
then he goes head forward from
southeast oklahoma state you he points
at robin
but rob would love it yeah so but show
the picture
how do you have that so that that's
rodman at 11 o'clock on on a sun on a
flight
you see when she's a nice milk and
coffee on the table that's good
what's in his hand though
that's your son right there lovely
family that's cool man anyway
robin's that's the good thing about
these things man when you when you when
you're in the sports world you got a lot
of great stories with that but you know
as we're going to wrap up here i'm
trying to see what story to pick i got a
few of them
cdc let's talk about cdc here i don't
know if you guys saw the reports or not
okay adam i'm going to go to you first
so reports came out i don't know if you
guys are listening to this if you heard
about the cdc reports okay
kai if you want to pull it up so we can
see one of the articles as well
uh covet cases decrease from cdc
on their site by the way on their site
uh on their site
uh uh i'm sure you'll figure out which
one it is here at this pace it may take
us a couple weeks when kai's on it but
we will get it okay 94
of all the deaths from covet 19 other
conditions are listed
in addition to covet 19. these causes
may include chronic conditions like
diabetes or hypertension
anderson said in the statement provided
to cnn by cdc
in six percent of the death certificate
that list covet 19
only one cause or condition is listed
okay the underlying case
cause of death is a condition that began
the chain of events that ultimately led
to the person's death 92
of all the deaths mentioned coveted 19
kobe 19 enlisted as the underlying cause
of death
on 6k six percent of those which means
what
out of everybody that died only six
percent covet was the main
and only case 94 there was
other causes so when they said covet has
killed
this many people have died because of
covet it's not
the main cause it's what they
had when they died due to other
reasons as well thoughts pat we should
be outraged at amer as a man i don't
know why we're not
i mean we should be revolting about this
this is disgusting it's
it's destroying the country the stuff
that we're believing i take the kirk
cousins approach
for the minnesota vikings i respect it
i'm not living in fear in it i'll give
you two
quick stories a business partner a good
friend of mine is a very renowned
plastic surgeon
uh he told me this is the meetings they
have that
when they do autopsies they test for
covid if you test positive no matter if
you died of a gunshot wound a car
accident or cancer
you will be listed that you died of
covet fact number two
have a very good friend in california
that her and some other people went to
go get tested
just to see right they went to the va to
do it because they could do it their
free it was free etc so the line was so
long
they filled out their paperwork when
they got there but the line was so long
they bailed a week later
they get a positive covid test result
in the mail even though they didn't take
the test so none of this stuff
can uh surprises me i i think we should
be
way way way more outraged at these
stories than we are i'll tell you what
we had a couple of our guys that got
tested in california
okay and the wife came out positive
the husband came out negative and the
wife's like i promise you
i have i don't have anything so she
flies to florida
when she flies to florida she gets
tested that same morning when she flies
to florida
guess what the results come about come
out in florida
within 12 hours the results are negative
and then you heard the 75 nfl players
yes that were falsely tested
positive you know and nobody talked
about it just all of a sudden was like
let's not bring it up it was how many
pittsburgh students were like 19 or
something
19 steelers tested positive and you know
the media wanted to just run with that
let's shut down the nfl
because even though it wasn't true i
mean it's terrible yeah
and then you got the whole story coming
back the rock just announced that
himself
yes his entire family they had covet and
they recovered from it
you you said the cousin's comment very
quickly can you say it slowly so
everybody can catch what he said so
yesterday or
you know earlier this week whenever
you're listening to this kirk cousins
well actually he did it on a podcast
quarterback for the minnesota vikings
right he did it on a podcast with kyle
brandt of the nfl network a popular
podcast that he has and
when kovitt came up you know he's uh
kirk's a very christian uh very
faith-driven individual
and and he said hey i don't live in fear
of this i would prefer not i will
i'll respect the fact that i have to
wear it but hey if i die i die
right meaning like he's going to live
his life how he has to he's not going to
be
you know flaunting it and try to get it
or anything but he's got enough faith
where he thinks you know
maybe this according to the data that i
have access to this isn't as bad
right so he got ripped for that so then
they had to move his media appearance up
one day so he could
so he could kind of like uh fix that
statement a little bit he didn't
backpedal from it too much but
you know what's wrong why can't you just
say hey
i do respect it it's out there it's real
but i'm not afraid of it you know and at
some point we have to
loosen some of the restrictions that
we're all living under and if data from
the cdc comes out like this
shouldn't that change some of the
shouldn't that lift some of these things
that we've had to live under for a long
time
i'm just going to take it back to the
conversation we had literally less than
a week ago yeah and with
matt ricky we were sitting back there
you know i don't want to use names
cigar conversation not the cigar when
we're sitting back here yeah
and the uh you and ricky were going at
it it was more
ricky was just asking me a million
different questions yeah but both of
them had
very entertaining yeah great guy great
guy wild man
hates capitalism right he's a complete
socialist
um loves capitalism um but they both had
covet both and i asked matt i mean not
to put their [ __ ] out there but you know
i was like
so is it real like tell me he's like
dude they kicked the [ __ ] out of me
but you know a handful of days later
yeah i
i was back up to speed you know we
obviously have our friend paulie who's
getting another shout out here he was
out of commission for
a few weeks kicked the [ __ ] out of him
but ricky said something that was pretty
profound he goes yeah i had it too man
this is no joke
but you know what i you know what i
discovered from this
and he basically kind of tentative into
this
it's take care of yourself bro like lose
weight if you're 350 pounds
you better lose some weight if you've
got diabetes you got to do something
about that
if you've got you know all these
underlying conditions
those are the people that this is truly
affecting if you're just a sloppy person
not living your best life not being
healthy get it together
because kova can come around and kick
the [ __ ] out of you but for the most
part if you're living a healthy
lifestyle you're taking care of your
um health health is wealth
you'll get the [ __ ] kicked out of you
with covid for you know a handful of
days for a week you could bounce back i
think that's the bottom line
is it not it is but but this
the whole topic here was that 94
of the reasons people died the number
one reason wasn't coveted
they happened to have coveted underlying
conditions underlying
conditions which means the data to be oh
my gosh
for example my dad is 7
8 years old a couple years ago he was
hospitalized for two weeks
okay because he had heart issues and he
had pneumonia at the same time yes
when he went to the hospital the doctors
were like ready this something could go
down and this could be so i went
everybody went to visit this guy
76 year olds should not be having
pneumonia it's not something that if a
seven
you know what it is when you i don't
know if you had pneumonia or not i've
had it before
i don't know if you had bronchitis
before it kicks your
ass if you had any of those two right so
what happens
you got to take the right probiotics you
got to take the right vitamins you got
to
figure out a way to stay strong but this
data is
manipulative this is putting fear into
the american people
as a form of a tactic to get people to
be scared
and it got people to agree to shut down
and stay home
jobs were lost tens of millions of jobs
were lost because people thought they
were going to die from covet yeah and
they're not saying hey we made a mistake
we had some false reporting here this is
a strategy
right i mean these decisions were made
to report it this way let me just ask a
question this is more
in general this is obviously cdc here in
america cdc's here in america okay
cool got that what's the rest of the
world saying about this because it's not
like covet's different
in you know europe than it is in america
doesn't care about cdc the cdc is u.s
right correct yeah but what do they say
their economies are in shambles they
they've shut down i mean china's really
done do you know why china's moved on
yeah
do you know why china's moved on tell me
what actually think about why china's
moved on
actually think about why china has been
they released the uh they said a hundred
days
covet free china and cnbc keeps putting
it on their instagram post
why do you think china is 100 days covet
free
why because they're not reporting the
truth because there is no free press
yeah you don't have the freedom to press
well what do you mean it's a hundred day
how do you know it's a hundred days free
you don't have it 1.3 billion bbc there
no
so yeah you believing the stats so when
i see cnn i'm not talking about china
yeah but
every other country cnbc is a credible
channel i mean this is cnbc nbc
when they say china's now officially 100
days code free
how the hell do you know and you're
you're essentially saying you trust the
data
how do you know and adam i think you
know the point is you know maybe a
thousand
people did die but not ninety thousand
and if if that's what they're saying
that is a real problem no one's saying
covet doesn't exist or it's not
dangerous or you shouldn't take some
sort of precautions but
94 of them actually didn't die of the
disease and that's
that's like unfathomable you know
something here's the other part i mean
we can we can go past the cdc this last
one i want to bring up because
uh my friend uh uh jose sent me this he
says hey pat you may want to talk about
this this what's going on california
right now i said okay let me look it up
at first when he sent me the post i'm
like there's no way i believe this thing
here then i went deeper
i said wait a minute this actually
happened so i don't know if you heard
about the california senate bill 145.
you and i briefly talked about it
right a little bit so kai if you want to
pull this up by the way when i tell you
this at first you are not going to be i
didn't understand it i i
mean i i can't run my head around yeah
so this is a a bill
in california state senate that was
passed would leave the decision of
whether individuals convicted a
particular
sex crimes involving minors must be
registered as
sex offenders to the discretion of the
court meaning
uh the bill would not shield anyone from
the requirement to register as a sex
offender
rather it would leave the decision
ineligible cases to the discretion of
the presiding judge
it would allow a sex offender who lures
a minor
with the intent to commit a felony sex
act
the ability to escape registering as a
sex offender as long as the offender is
within 10 years of the age of the minor
so if a 21 year old if a 21 year old
gets together with a 12 year old girl
that's not a sex offender freaking
ridiculous if a
20 21 and 12. as long as it's 10 years
okay this is california and by the way
this is all out there so
a big part of it is on protecting the
lgbtq community
they're using that as a method of
protecting them
i've never heard of a bill before and
the senators the state senator scott
weiner
from san francisco democrats actually
assemblyman
defend your people here you're you're in
california what's going on do you guys
care if i just
make one quick phone call u-haul
yeah i'll take two 26-footers
yeah they'll be going east yeah next
thursday okay
hang on what the hell is going on here
tom hey i can't defend these guys don't
make me speak for them it's unbelievable
did you know this no i didn't know it
until you mentioned it it's unbelievable
california and you know and you know
with all the other stuff going on in the
world something like this can sneak
under the radar right
what other what is anybody voting for
out there
okay i can understand i don't want the
you know the the police to come and get
me i can understand if you're talking
about a
27 year old and a 17 year old cool
they're doing some weird stuff
you know lgbt you're talking about a 22
year old and a 12 year old you're
talking about a 19 or a 9 year old
what the [ __ ] are we talking about here
that's what are we talking about here
that's what they're talking about
ridiculous 19 and a 9 year old if it's
less than
10 years you're not a sex what are we
talking about here this is ridic how is
someone passing this
that's california i don't understand it
so you asked the question
listen i have friends who are armenian
who are having their mom they're that
glendale is
armenian county glendale is the second
armenian of the world i mean everybody
in glendale is army you know this you go
to court
everyone's armenian if you live in
glendale for too long you will look
armenia that's how
armenian glendale is right matter of
fact i'm not armenia
[Laughter]
but armenians in glendale who
will not leave their parents who will
not leave their families
who will not leave their 22 cousins that
they have living in california
they're flat out telling me i can't do
this anymore
and everyone's losing it what the hell
is going on over here
this is some strange things right here
man when this happens this is
freaky deaky like insane stuff here
here's the scary thing that he's so
out of the box by the way if anybody's
watching this have any one of you guys
been following the story senate bill 143
145 if you have been comment below on
how you feel about it go ahead no i was
just going to say
even introducing a bill like this should
get you
knocked out or or voted out or something
but then to actually get it across
and get it passed it it's and ironically
it's sponsored by
senator scott weiner
yeah susan your entire life you can call
the wiener you know you're mentally
you have issues but there wasn't another
wiener guy
and he got in trouble for showing his
wiener the last names of wieners man you
gotta you gotta just uh keep it together
keep it to yourself by the way
i saw this interview last week with your
buddy this is a guy that
adam loves he just loves him who was the
guy saying brian uh uh
stelter stelter okay i do not love him
we all know that the
guy on cnn we have to finish the car
entertainment so watch what happens here
so
because over the last three and a half
plus you know months
thinking it's going good gotten to see
you know the exposure of how the fourth
estate has completely been uh
burned down uh if you brian do you
believe in polls
i do believe in polls yeah okay very
good well the last poll that i saw
from a reliable course was that in 1970
let's talk about walter cronkite for a
second
the united states believed that the
media was giving them
real factual information a new poll just
came out that said it's completely the
opposite so 80
believed in the media in 1970 and now
20 does so 80 doesn't
so when i look at that i look at this is
very unreliable sources
and you guys always talk about how many
times trump has lied
i've calculated that i think with your
chiron
with you know i don't know if there's
any journalists left at cnn
but i know that you know if i were to
estimate about 300 different
you know distortions or misinformation
that we get out of cnn
and you have to watch them in the
airport which is harsh
but if you added all that up to 46
months it comes out to be 300
000 plus distortions of truth
so my thing is here is that
you guys this is how low you'll go is
that you went out
and you made you made lies and
you uh you defamed
a child and then you had to settle
out of court to pay this child for
distorting information about this
young individual so i would say you know
if anything that's happening at cnn
and anybody who buys your book it's
really just
one of those things that is dividing our
nation and
i don't believe in dividing our nation
it hurts our great nation
and we got to hear his response about
that cnn is really the enemy coming up
here
and that's my opinion thank you brian
stelter
i i'm grateful for the call and i know
that you're not the only person that
feels this way there has been a process
of radicalization that's happened in
this country
with media bashing that is absolutely
unprecedented
you know 20 30 years ago conservatives
talked about media bias
and there were some really valid points
to that critique it is absolutely true
that lots of journalists are based in
new york and washington they're based in
big cities they have liberal leadings
and mainstream newsrooms are built to
make sure that that bias doesn't seep
into the news coverage and yet sometimes
it does i absolutely acknowledge that
you're from donald hickory north
carolina good morning pause that
okay go ahead you know here here's the
problem with him
and his other people they they live you
talk about the nba bubble these guys
these these people at cnn and media
outlets like that they live in their own
bubble
they don't allow any other differing
opinion
so they're surrounded all day in their
assignment meetings and and throughout
the day by
only people that believe one particular
thing
and and then they buy into it and they
figure out how to sell it i bet he got
in trouble when he got back to cnn
for not interrupting the caller sooner
or shot or shooting him down
or calling him a quack or something i
was surprised he actually took there and
listened to it that long
adam yeah the most shocking part of that
interview is i googled how old brian
stelter is you know how old that guy is
47. he's 35 years old dude i don't he's
not aging gracefully he is not
he's not 35. 35 years old that is not a
good looking gentleman at age 35 jesus
can you imagine what he looks like at 45
um that's the most disappointing part of
this entire interview
hit age kai 35 years old there it is
from damascus
unbelievable talk about what the what
the media do to you
yeah i mean i think look the same thing
that can be said about cnn can be said
about
fox news the same thing that can be said
about msnbc can be it can be said about
breitbart
this is the problem with the media we
talked about 1970 80 percent of the
people
believed it was coming out of the media
walter cronkite respect
uh 20 these days that's a very very sad
number
uh media bias is real what i will give
him credit for
is like what tom said owning up to it
he's like yeah you know
yep it's something it's a problem and we
we got to get better at it so
at least we're having the conversation
right i mean it's it'd be a fascinating
topic to go deep into
and say when did it change right because
the media has always you know had their
issues and i worked in the media i
worked in newsrooms for 15 years
i didn't i didn't you know you don't
check in you were there in the mid-90s
yeah i mean you're you're
you're part of the problem tom right
you're nbc
liberal elite i was at the tv station
that brought jerry springer in to do the
nightly commentary but you know
something
something what happened what changed
since the 90s since you and rodman were
taking kamikaze shots
something must have changed china i
think china got a hold of our social
media and they're
you can always watch this you'll have a
safe comfort zone here if you're blaming
it on china 80
trusted the media to 20 that's right and
by the way
what uh alan lichtman said the american
people they said the number is
just as low with the government so the
american people don't trust the media or
the government today who the hell do you
trust do you trust
that's exactly that's the question but
the best part about this is
hopefully if you don't trust the media
and you don't trust
the government hopefully this will force
you to go to your own due diligence and
listen
to both sides hope right hopefully that
is that is a call to action to everyone
out there if you're right-leaning and
you're all about trump
go go listen to some liberal leaning
information if you're a leftist
socialist
go listen to the other side form your
own opinion it's very easy to get caught
up in a vacuum
live in your bubble and form your own
opinion i agree and be dug in and that's
my opinion and i ain't changing it yeah
but pat
why is it up you just mentioned the two
entities we distrust the most
the media and the politicians
so what are we going to do on election
day we're never going to find out who
wins this thing because we won't believe
he's telling us
we won't believe who was involved in the
election we're going to be in this we're
probably going to do the podcast live
during election day to go through the
whole thing and that may
be a long time and maybe like a six hour
podcast that day like a
you know uh oh yeah it'll be a long like
a philippines and it'll never get bored
it's gonna be bathroom breaks i don't
know if i can make it six
hours i don't know i gotta wear diapers
i gotta wear bad words diapers me and
nancy pelosi by the way
last one put this video by the way this
next video we're gonna show you it's not
true but we gotta give credit
to whoever did this bring in your diaper
by the way this
is not uh this is not go back live
this morning from new york hey good
morning
wake up
wake up wake up it's not real but it's
hilarious
can we actually play the real video
though um
can we can we play the real video played
a real video you know who the real video
was with
much respect for harry belafonte sir
hairy bellaphone
that was who it was watch harry
belafonte asleep that's who it was
so you know again you got to do your own
research everybody listen i said it's
not
real but it's still hollow second one
kai
they like live this morning from new
york
hey good morning harry harry wake up
harry looks cooler though doesn't he
yeah and he looks like he's dead
wake up and he snores in tune okay
i don't know if you read his book about
his story there's actually
he's there true sorry yeah yeah it's a
true story harry belafonte he's got
respect to harry potter he's got a very
good story he's that he's had a very
good story very good life so
okay all good i think it's fair to say
that we come to the end
of our podcast we hit a record high
today i think we cracked
1980. if you enjoyed today's podcast put
a thumbs up and press that subscribe
button and
the alert so you get alerted every time
these things come out and
uh again it's good to have tom on as a
first time with us a lot of you guys
were asking us what's tom's
name i'm gonna put it down here tom
zenner with two
ends tom zenner if you want to look them
up tom zenner you can look them up we
will do the podcast again
kyle we schedule for next tuesday as of
right now what's the time that we have a
schedule for
i believe we are scheduled for next
tuesday if we
uh uh uh if we it's next tuesday same
time stay tuned for it again we'll do it
next tuesday same time
eight o'clock have a great weekend we'll
do this again
next week bye bye bye bye bye bye
you